pero no
nos encontramos en una sala no muy
grande llamada la sala de la signatura
saturada no sólo por el número de
personas sino por la cantidad de
imágenes en ella vemos frescos pintados
por rafael durante el alto renacimiento
mientras miguel ángel pintaba el techo
de la capilla sixtina a poca distancia
esta sala era originalmente una
biblioteca parte de las habitaciones
papales es decir donde vivía el papá
para tener una mejor idea de cómo pudo
haber sido este salón a principios del
siglo 16 imagina que sacamos a todas
estas personas y que hay libros en todas
las paredes inferiores todo en silencio
y un ambiente de aprendizaje donde al
levantar la mirada veías lo que rafael
pintó aquí en las cuatro paredes que son
las cuatro ramas del conocimiento humano
la filosofía que tiene que ver con los
asuntos de este mundo en ese tiempo la
filosofía también abarcaba lo que ahora
llamamos ciencia en la pared opuesta a
la teología los asuntos de dios y lo
divino
en las otras dos paredes la poesía y la
justicia estas cuatro áreas del
conocimiento humano están simbolizadas
por alegorías que vemos en el techo y
podemos ver claramente que sólo a unas
cuantas puertas de distancia se
encuentran miguelángel porque rafael
está viendo las figuras de miguel ángel
en el techo de la capilla sixtina
especialmente a los profetas y civiles
que momento del alto renacimiento
todo esto fue comisionado por el papá
julio segundo piensa en lo que significa
que la teología se presente al lado del
conocimiento humano un momento sumamente
liberal en la historia de la iglesia
cuando el aprendizaje clásico de los
humanistas se une a las enseñanzas de la
iglesia en el centro de la escuela de
atenas el fresco que representa la
filosofía tenemos a los dos grandes
filósofos de la antigüedad platón y
aristóteles rodeados por otros grandes
pensadores filósofos y matemáticos de la
antigüedad casi todos los personajes
conocidos pero comencemos por los dos
del centro podemos diferenciar a platón
de aristóteles porque platón es más
anciano platón fue maestro de arista
pero también porque lleva uno de sus
propios libros el timeo y aristóteles
lleva su libro la ética ambos libros
representan los pensamientos
contrastantes de estos dos filósofos a
platón se le reconoce por su interés en
lo etéreo lo teórico lo que no puede ser
visto y de hecho lo vemos apuntando
hacia arriba él afirmaba que el mundo
visible no es la verdad última que
existe un reino basado en las
matemáticas en la idea pura que es más
verdadera que lo que vemos a diario
por otro lado aristóteles su alumno fijó
su atención en lo observable lo real lo
físico puedes ver que la palma de su
mano está hacia abajo y parece estar
diciendo no fijémonos en lo que está
aquí en lo que podemos ver y observar en
el mundo además los colores de las ropas
de cada uno hacen referencia a esta
división platón visten colores violetas
y rojos el violeta se referencia al éter
o aire y el rojo el fuego elementos
ingrávidos mientras que aristóteles
viste en tonos marrón y azul los colores
de la tierra y el agua ambos elementos
tienen peso los filósofos
a cada lado continúan con esta división
del lado de platón vemos filósofos que
se ocuparon de los asuntos de lo ideal
por ejemplo en el extremo inferior vemos
a pitágoras el gran matemático de la
antigüedad que descubriera las leyes de
la armonía en la música y las
matemáticas esta idea de que hay una
realidad que trasciende a la realidad
que vemos compara eso con la esquina
inferior derecha donde vemos euclides a
quien asociamos con la geometría parece
estar dibujando un diagrama geométrico
para algunos entusiastas le interesa la
medición es decir lo práctico el que
sirvió de modelo para euclides era amigo
de rafael llamado bramante el gran
arquitecto a quien el papá julio segundo
le pidiera un proyecto para una nueva
basílica de san pedro y es muy apropiada
su reencarnación aquí como euclides pues
el diseño de bramante para la basílica
se basaba en una geometría perfecta de
círculos y cuadrados
en la arquitectura que rafael construyó
para la escuela de atenas es muy notoria
la influencia de bramante y al mismo
tiempo muy acorde con la roma antigua
tenemos bóvedas de cañón artesonado y
pilastras es un espacio que noble sea
los personajes pintados en él también
vemos representaciones de la escultura
clásica en los nichos de la izquierda
del lado de platón vemos a apolo el dios
del sol de la música de la poesía
elementos muy relacionados con lo
platónico y a la derecha vemos a atenea
la diosa de la guerra y la sabiduría más
relacionada con los asuntos prácticos
del hombre la escuela de atenas parece
oponerse a lo medieval cuando el
conocimiento se transmitía por autoridad
y había que aceptarlo pero aquí en las
paredes de la habitación papal tenemos
esta sensación de que el conocimiento se
está compartiendo se muestra la historia
de la acumulación del conocimiento con
hermosas imágenes que se mueven con
gracia sus cuerpos reflejan su sabiduría
y conocimiento
er nos rafael no puso nombres dentro de
la pintura quizá lo único que los
identifica son los títulos de los libros
que portan tanto platón como aristóteles
y nos pide entender quiénes son ellos a
través de sus movimientos y sus
vestimentas el artista ha dividido ambos
grupos a la izquierda y a la derecha y
el centro está casi vacío y lo hace por
dos razones quiere lograr la perspectiva
lineal en la parte inferior de la
pintura para equilibrar los sólidos
ortogonales en la parte superior y a la
vez abrir paso para que platón y
aristóteles puedan bajar las escaleras
pero en la parte frontal central tenemos
dos figuras diógenes y aún más
interesante heráclito filósofo de la
antigüedad quien parece estar
escribiendo y pensando en silencio él
solo la mayoría de las otras personas en
la pintura están interactuando con otros
pero no este hombre parece estar sumido
en sus propios pensamientos y está
escribiendo sobre un bloque de mármol y
sus rasgos son los del gran artista
miguel ángel conocido por su
personalidad más bien solitaria y
sombría rafael lo ha pintado aquí en la
misma pose que él
e isaías en el techo de la capilla
sixtina
aunque isaías mira hacia arriba y aquí
él heráclito miguel ángel mira hacia
abajo rafael rinde tributo a miguel
ángel el gran artista personificándolo
como heráclito el filósofo que creía que
todas las cosas estaban en cambio
incesante en realidad esta figura de
heráclito es posterior
rafael terminó los frescos agrego un
poco de estuco y añadió esa imagen
también debemos observar que rafael se
incluyó a sí mismo es el joven mirando
directamente hacia nosotros con una
boina negra rodeado por los astrónomos
más importantes de la historia
incluyendo ptolomeo quien habló sobre
los movimientos de los planetas y
zoroastro quien sostiene la órbita
celeste estamos tan lejos de la
concepción medieval del artista como
artesano aquí el artista se considera un
intelectual está a la par de los más
grandes pensadores de la historia
alguien que puede expresar estas ideas
importantes tenemos docenas de figuras
aquí sin ningún sentido de rigidez o
repetición rafael como leonardo en la
última escena de vida
personajes en grupos y cada personaje se
mueve libremente entre los otros mis
personajes favoritos son los que están
justo detrás de euclides uno recargado
contra la pared con una pierna cruzada
sobre la otra
escribiendo apresuradamente y el otro
inclinado observando hay una sensación
de intimidad aquí es una escena que
podrías ver en los pasillos de cualquier
universidad y para que los personajes se
puedan mover libremente la arquitectura
emplea una rigurosa perspectiva lineal
se pueden seguir los ortogonales tanto
en el piso como en las cornisas mientras
estas se alejan así que la ilusión de
espacio es increíble observa como la
decoración griega con meandros parece
como retroceder en el espacio si bien
esta arquitectura evoca alguna cultura
de la antigüedad lo hace a la romana y
no a la griega quienes nunca utilizaron
bóvedas artes sonadas como estas cerca
de ahí bramante rafael y miguel ángel
podían ver las termas de caracalla o la
basílica de majencio y constantino había
ruinas arquitectónicas romanas por toda
la ciudad similares a las que rafael
pintó aquí es como si nos encontráramos
en él
panteón de los célebres pensadores
paganos ninguno de estos hombres era
cristiano pero veamos rápidamente el
fresco frente a la escuela de atenas
conocida como la disputa del sacramento
este fresco representa la teología el
estudio de lo divino las imágenes aquí
están divididas entre lo celestial y lo
terrenal casi hasta arriba vemos a dios
padre en el domo celestial bajo el
cristo con un magnífico halo de cuerpo
entero o mandorla con la virgen maría a
su derecha y san juan bautista a la
izquierda justo abajo se encuentra una
paloma recargada sobre otro disco dorado
el espíritu santo los tres juntos forman
la trinidad a cada lado de la paloma se
encuentran los cuatro evangelios mateo
marcos lucas y juan que narran la
historia de la vida de cristo en esa
estupenda banca de nube se sientan los
profetas y santos podemos reconocer por
ejemplo a moisés sosteniendo los diez
mandamientos luego otro círculo más
abajo contiene la [ __ ] o el pan que
milagrosamente se transforma en el
cuerpo de cristo' durante la misa
y pan funge como el lazo entre el cielo
y la tierra podemos ver cuán separados
están el cielo de la tierra en este
fresco y la importancia de ese lazo las
figuras en la parte inferior son papas
obispos cardenales y miembros de varias
órdenes religiosas podemos ver un
retrato de dante el gran poeta medieval
pareciera que las figuras en la parte
inferior del fresco vienen a adquirir
conocimiento divino a través del milagro
de la [ __ ] dos figuras una a cada
extremo parecen estar alejándose de ese
conocimiento divino pero están
intentando convencer las de regresar
aquí en la sala de la signatura lo que
fuera la biblioteca del papá julio
segundo se vive una celebración en todos
los aspectos del conocimiento humano
o no